this story about getting your entire
family to take MDMA so a couple years
ago I took Ayahuasca for the first time
after a breakup and it was very
impactful so I continued down this path
of psychedelic therapy having never done
any sort of having been off alcohol for
eight years at that point so this was
like a big deal for me after
experimenting with Ayahuasca 5mo DMT
psilocybin then MDMA I found that MDMA
was the one that was easiest to
recommend to newbies and that's because
MDMA is like a warm blanket being
wrapped around you that gives you the
courage to dive into your traumas and
what you made of them and one by one
went to my family and said I really want
you to do this and what ultimately I
think got them to agree was the changes
that they saw in me particularly my dad
didn't want to go I started telling him
like a charismatic person this would be
good for you and I think it would be
good for your life and what ultimately I
think moved him was the authentic truth
which is I need you to do this so I can
feel close to you